throughout this crisis my priority has
always been to protect jobs
so today i'm announcing an expansion of
our job support scheme
specifically to protect those jobs of
people who work in businesses that may
be asked to close
if that happens those workers will
receive two-thirds of their wages for
the time that they're unable
to go to work i hope that this provides
reassurance and a safety net
for people and businesses in advance of
what may be a difficult winter
have you estimated how much that's going
to cost do you know
how much how you're going to pay for it
we obviously won't know the exact
take-up of a scheme like this because as
we enter an uncertain period the exact
scope of any restrictions that may be
necessary is uncertain at this time
we also have all the costings for the
previous schemes that we've done that
are available
but it's right that we take action now
to protect people's jobs
provide that reassurance if indeed their
businesses are asked to close
throughout the winter the fact that
you're asking
and announcing this scheme today does
seem to suggest that you are as a
government going to ask
some businesses to close possibly uh in
the hospitality sector
can you say anything about which
businesses
how much for how long give any sense
for all of those millions of people who
are hanging on government decisions
what's coming next well obviously the
rise in
cases and hospital admissions in certain
parts of the country
is a concern it's right that the
government considers a range of options
to address that and considers all the
evidence but it's also right that they
engage with local leaders and that's
what is happening this afternoon and
over the weekend so those conversations
can happen
and collectively we can decide on the
appropriate response
now the hospitality sector and pubs
don't want to be shut unnecessarily how
can you make absolutely sure that under
what we're told is the tier system
that's coming
um that uh which can look like a bit of
a blunt instrument we're not going to
end up
in a situation where lots of places are
being closed without
need and without an exit strategy
i think it's absolutely right that we
consider all the evidence and have these
conversations together
and consider all of these decisions in
the round i mean we know the impact that
this virus is having not just
on our economy we want to make sure we
protect children's education
and people's health conditions not just
coronavirus all of these are things in
the round that we need to
talk about with regard to the
hospitality industry or other businesses
that may be asked to close
i'm also announcing today an increase in
the generosity and frequency
of business grants that will go to those
businesses up to 3 000 pounds a month
paid every fortnight which will also
help them if they find themselves in
this unfortunate situation
over the summer you encourage people to
go to pubs
back into restaurants with your eat out
to help out scheme now hospitality is
being blamed for the second spike
two weeks ago you didn't look like you
wanted to do anything like this kind of
partial
furlough uh which you've rebranded the
extension of the job support scheme
um now you're having to do it is there
any sense in which the treasury is
guilty of a bit of wishful thinking
and isn't what's going wrong why are you
having to do these u-turns
well this is a very different scheme to
what we've had before
this is not a universal approach this is
an expansion of the job support scheme
specifically
for those people who are in businesses
that will be formally or legally asked
to close so in that sense it's very
different
but i've always said that we will adapt
and evolve
our response as the situation on the
health side
adapts and evolve that's what's
happening i think that's the pragmatic
and the right thing to do to adapt to
that
and i believe that the actions today
demonstrate that approach final question
the prime minister has said nobody who
does the right thing
should lose out from coronavirus today
you're effectively announcing a pay cut
what do you say to all those people who
will get less money each month
in their salary as a result of today's
announcements well
throughout this entire crisis we've
tried to protect people's jobs
and incomes to a considerable degree
that's what the furlough scheme did it
protected almost nine million jobs
that's what today's announcement will do
protect the jobs that income of people
who happen to work in businesses that
may be asked to shut down
and with all the other measures we've
made whether it's changes to our welfare
system mortgage holidays support for
businesses
we've made sure that the most vulnerable
in our society are the ones that have
been protected the most and that's
something that we will continue to do
you